thanks for tuning into the special
edition of Google developers live today
we're featuring rush misogyny from girls
who code in celebration of Computer
Science Education Week hello and thanks
for joining us my name is Dina shocker
and I work with Google org the social
impact arm of Google I'm thrilled today
to introduce and welcome my friend
Reshma so Johnnie the founder of girls
who code a role model and public figure
who is here to talk about her incredible
vision and work with this organization
who we are thrilled to be supporting
welcome Reshma and thank you so much for
joining us I'm so happy to be here we're
thrilled to have you I'd like to start
off with a question about your own story
and if you could tell us a bit about
your career which has traversed so many
different fields and has landed you in
that with this incredible organization
from law to politics to finance and now
to girls who code can you tell us a bit
about what ultimately landed you on this
incredible idea sure um
so in 2010 I was running for Congress
and as you know is someone who has a
long career in politics when you run for
office you talk to a lot of parents you
go to a lot of schools you meet a lot of
kids and my district had some of the
wealthiest of codes in America and some
of the poorest and I remember being in
these schools and watching some girls
like who barely had a teacher who could
help them use a computer and then some
places that had more gadgets than kids
knew what to do with and as someone was
passionate about policy you know it's
clear where the jobs are gonna be there
in the computing and technology related
fields almost 1.4 million jobs by 2020
but less than 15 percent of them are
going to be filled by women even though
we are 50% of the labor force 50% of
those graduate early owned the internet
but young girls are not going into these
fields and so I wanted to do something
about it
and so I brought 20 girls together put
them into a classroom and technology
company convened a bunch of computer
scientists and academics to develop a
curriculum that was very targeted at
girls and I thought let's see what
happened and it was a tremendous first
year because all of our girls learned
how to code because that wasn't clear
when we first put them in
classroom and AppNexus and to they fell
in love with computer science and they
built things that would change the world
and I we realized that we were really on
to something and that we needed to get
the resources together to really have
more girls who are learning computer
science education that's fantastic so
can you tell us a bit about where girls
who code is now and and how you went
from that group of twenty girls to what
is going to be a nationwide and
potentially international movement yeah
so we started with 20 girls in New York
and the following year we went from one
program to eight programs so we taught
about 152 girls in New York Detroit and
then in captain California and this year
our goal is to launch sixteen programs
have classes in Boston Seattle New York
California and Miami and to also through
the support of Google to launch girls
who code clubs because we realized that
you know young girls are not monolithic
right on one hat on one end of the
spectrum there are girls that know
they're passionate about technology they
just don't know where to go
and that's really our summer immersion
program or eight-week intensive summer
camp where the girl girls learn the
basics of computer science education
they get exposure to female mentors and
role models and you know they get it
they learn how to build stuff that
changes the world
our girls who code clubs are the place
to really your first experience with
computer science right so we have two
hours of coding a week resulting in 36
hours of coding a year and we hope that
these girls who code clubs will become
funnels into our summer camp or a summer
program great so in coming up with your
methodology and curriculum can you talk
a bit about what it is that
differentiates girls who code and and
how the curriculum is tailored in such a
way as to attract more girls
specifically so we really convened
people who had experience in one to not
only computer science but in teaching
girls and so we you know made sure that
our curriculum expose young girls to
like I said female mentors but also got
them the fundamentals and the basics
because you know oftentimes I think
girls think computers life is too hard
like I can't do this and they have to
get really used to failure and getting
the code or getting the algorithm wrong
and then trying again and then trying
again and then trying again and then
they also have to build things that are
about changing the world when you ask
most high school girls what they want to
do with their life they want to change
the world
career that's gonna help them do that
that's why you see more young girls
going into medicine going into law even
going into forensic science because they
see the clear relationship between those
industries and change and so our
curriculum makes that connection to them
you know in in or in a specific context
right so we have twitter come and they
build something on their API you know we
do projects with Intel with Google so
they can actually create things using
their you know using their API to
actually to change the world and to
build products that are gonna help them
do that
it sounds like they come up with a
pretty amazing project amazing projects
I remember our first year and we had a
girl who was five years old when her
father got diagnosed with cancer and so
she wanted to be a doctor because she
wanted to save her dad's life and she
didn't know how computer science was
connected to medicine until the last two
weeks or a program where she built an
algorithm to help detect whether a
cancer is benign or malignant she's 16
years old this year I remember the most
awesome experience was the girls had an
opportunity to meet Sheryl Sandberg and
so we're all sitting around this
conference room and Sheryl walk you know
walks you know past the the conference
room had these huge windows and the
girls literally start screaming like she
was Beyonce right was awesome like these
create these amazing little girl geeks
right so excited to see Sheryl Sandberg
and then they get up and choose in
threes and they present to Sheryl the
Facebook apps that they had built and
they were fearless like unabashed I
don't know if I could have done that at
16 right present to the CEO of Facebook
and to tell her why that they should
take the app that they built and put it
into market it was amazing
and so huge for them in terms of
confidence building so our girls have
built video games they you know they
built an app called let it flow to help
find a public bathroom you know which is
again an important thing you know they
built apps on bullying they built and
anything that you could think of but I
think the common thread is they built
things that were about making their
communities better helping their
families again making the world a better
place that's where their interest level
is really at so computer science and
technology is no longer a separate field
it's a way of doing everything right can
you talk about why it's important for us
to have diverse minds helping to create
the products that we
and everyday certain oh I just think
it's about having the best and the
brightest minds helping us solve
everyday problems and to me is just
crazy right when you think about the
fact that you know last year 4,000 girls
took the AP Computer Science exam that's
it
only seven less than 7,500 women
graduated in computer science again
defining that broadly even though 56% of
our labor force are women we just simply
can't out-innovate you know as an as a
nation unless we have half of our labor
force again working to solve these
problems and you know we talked about
this the United States is also kind of
behind when it comes to other nations
right the Middle East in some countries
and released more female engineers India
more female engineers China more female
engineers like around the world they are
inspiring their young girls to kind of
stand up and raise our hand and say I
want to become a computer scientist I
want to be a software engineer I want to
be a programmer we need to do the same
thing in this country because our
economy is changing we're moving away
from being a manufacturing base to a
service based economy we're going to
have to build things and every person in
order to think about I mean I hate to
say this but it's like I tell parents
it's like don't tell your kids to major
in East Asian Studies anymore I hope you
didn't measure anything we need to meet
you get a job and you can make $80,000 a
year being a programmer write a lot it's
a lot of money
for families here in this country and we
see that happen with our young girls
many of them who come from underserved
communities when they graduate girls are
code like they're able to build websites
they're getting jobs to do that and so
they're gonna lift their families out of
poverty and put them you know into
upward mobility into the middle class by
learning this 21st century skill set
that is so critical mm-hmm there's been
a narrative over the last two decades
really on girls in stem sort of more
broadly and in science technology and
medicine and engineering why is it you
think that for computer science
specifically there's actually been an
attrition in the number of women
majoring in computer science in the life
twenty years whereas many of the other
fields are actually rising right I mean
Steve Jobs probably had more women on
his original team than any tech
entrepreneur has today so they're it's
the one industry where there's actually
been a decline I've been giving a lot of
thought to this I mean I think it has a
lot to do with culture and you know 20
years ago it was the Barbie right who
said math is tough let's go shopping
right and just two years ago I bought a
t-shirt that says you know basically
algebra sucks you know in forever 21 so
culture has still told young girls math
and science are not for you it's okay to
say that you're not good at it even
though you really are we're sending the
exact wrong messages to our young girls
and we need to flip it and we need to
use pop culture to actually inspire our
young girls to get involved in
technology and that's what we're doing
at girls who code I mean we had one of
the things we did with our girls in
Detroit is they built you know their had
their robots dance to the Harlem shake
you know they actually did it with them
I mean we're using pop culture you know
to get girls excited about computer
science yeah how do you think your life
would have been different if you had the
chance for dissipate and girls who put
when you were not so much different I
mean I grew up with a both parents
remind we're engineers and I was
terrified of math and science growing up
and it lasted throughout my career
throughout my career in finance
throughout my grand politics and even
for me now it's so much of what I do
when I was in politics was about
building my website right being able to
communicate on social media I wish that
I could go in and make a change on my
website by myself you know one of the
things that we've done at girls our code
this year is really mandate that
everybody on staff including me has to
learn how to code you know we can't be
an organization that is promoting
computer science if all of our employees
don't also under you know don't also
know how to go I mean I really believe
that the future is about mandatory CS
education we need it yeah it definitely
is 21st century literacy and there's a
big language barrier particularly in
tech that increasingly across all fields
if you can't speak the language right
it's like reading and writing mm-hmm
exactly
so we have an audience of developers
here how can developers and parents and
adults who are interested in helping to
promote computer science education for
girls help you out yeah so through this
amazing partnership that we have with
Google
more volunteers you know we have set out
to teach thousands of girls how to code
through our girls who code clubs and
since we have a dearth of computer
science teachers in our country we are
reliant on volunteers and these
volunteers are developers and so anybody
who is you know watching this you know
please sign up to volunteer at a girls
who code club which we're launching in
New York Detroit we have clubs in Boston
you know and then you know here in
California we had a hundred girls show
up at the San Diego Public Library to
learn how to code it's amazing yeah
what's happening and we can teach as
many girls as we have volunteer teachers
to teach excellent now if you're
successful in your mission where do you
see the ecosystem at in five years in
ten years ah so I think that this is
kind of a 2050 problem and I have to
tell myself that every day right because
many of our successes are incremental
and they feel like it's slow but it's
really fast if that makes sense again I
go back to telling myself you know in
the 70s 10% of women were lawyers and
doctors and now that number is almost
over 40% less than you know 40 years
later that's where I want to be that's
where we want to be as an organization
so it's gonna take some time and it's
gonna take collaboration which we've
also talked about there's so many
amazing organizations that are in this
space you know from black girls code to
code org to what Goldilocks did last you
know two weeks ago with her Beastie Boy
you know video that was like inspired so
many young girls I mean my ten year old
niece you know is learning how to code
through code Academy so we all are
working together to really solve this
tremendous tremendous problem which i
think is again the most important
domestic issue of our time how can
parents specifically help to encourage
their girls to get in to see our parents
are our biggest advocates I mean studies
show the Girl Scouts did a great study
of girls in STEM and it showed that most
of the girls that went into stem it was
because of a parent a parent had
encouraged them to go into something to
introduce them to an engineer or a
programmer they had opened up this
amazing world to them so parents are key
to that also when we think about how we
get volunteers in our clubs it's having
a parent who's an advocate at a school
who can actually teach who can like
change the minds of administrators
making this an important issue parents
are voters you know we still don't have
enough elected officials around the
country who realize how critical of an
issue this is and so we all need to be
basically staying
up stepping up and saying that this is
something that we need to push as a
nation thank you so much for joining us
freshmen for your incredible efforts in
this organization and and all the work
that you do to get more girls into
computer science
thank you helping to shape the future of
our world Thank You Tina and thank you
for everything that you and Google have
done to really support our organization
we wouldn't be able to do this work
without you thank you for joining us
we've been sitting down with Reshma so
Johnny the founder of girls who code for
more information on girls who code check
them out online girls who code comm make
sure to join in on the fun at CS ed week
org where you can participate in an hour
of code during computer science
education week